well Us helicopters have sunk three
small houie boats in the southern Red
Sea as the Yemen group attempts to
pressure Israel into ending the war the
US Navy received a second distress call
from a m container ship on Sunday
morning uie boats had got to within 20
MERS of the vessel shot at crew and
tried to get on board they also opened
fire on the US helicopters the container
ship had already been struck by houi
missile on Saturday well r s joins us
live from jibou now uh for more on this
and uh as we've seen an increasing
number of incidents are they raising
concerns about the effectiveness of this
Naval
Mission indeed so the USA has said that
it has formed a multinational task force
in the Red Sea to deter who is from
attacking the commercial ships
commercial wessels here however
practically there is not much that we
can see that is acting under the command
of this Coalition rather we see that USA
is increasing his Naval presence here
and the warships that are engaging in
fighting against the huis are the US
warships not the Coalition warship so in
the last 24 hours the three attacks and
now for the first time since the
beginning of the crisis D is saying that
they didn't only sank three blls but
also kill the crew so this is the first
time that we we see that USA says that
they have killed some Hui members as of
now we do not know whether there's going
to be a retaliation from huis or not but
certainly there is an escalation here
and one of the failure or the failure
regarding the effectiveness of this
Coalition is that m one of the largest
global shipping companies has just
announced that it is going to suspend
The wessels Passage through the Red Sea
for the next 48 hours so there has been
a remarkable decrease in the number of
the ships that are passing through the
Ry up to 40% and now there's a huge
escalation so the USA hasn't been able
to deter hes the huis are saying that as
long as long as Israel continues his
killing in Gaza they are going to
continue to to to to attack the wessels
that are linked to linked to the the
Israel and USA on the other hand is not
stepping back it's increasing its
military presence here so no one knows
what is going to be the way out of this
crisis and this is causing fear among
yemenis they believe that the USA might
retaliate huies not only in the Red Sea
but who to targeting hu's position
within Yemen and they say that if that
happens there going to be a full fled
War that's why more and more yemenese
are now fleeing their country and coming
to
jouti